congratulations on this man it's really
really funny it's a great season what
was it like putting on the pink bow tie
for the first time were you like oh yeah
I remember this yeah it was really
special I think we we all kind of
freaked out when we finally were there
putting the ties on and just with each
other and the thing that freaked me out
was not only seeing everybody together
which we've you know gotten together
over the years here and there uh but
seeing everyone play those characters
again was sort of shocking how much it
moved me and and and how much I missed
these characters and it was just kind of
Off to the Races
now it's a party down reunion what
everyone's dying for yeah I mean
obviously you know we're missing Lizzy
was there any ever any hesitation in
moving forward without Lizzy did you
guys talk what was that conversation
like yeah it was really hard you know
Lizzy wanted to do it badly we of course
uh planned on having Lizzy uh be a part
of the season and it just wasn't
possible uh schedule wise
um but I think when when it became clear
that that she wasn't gonna be able to be
on the show uh John came up with a great
solution which is what what you see it's
with the card like why is it weirdly big
no this what's party down
with an M we lose Lizzy but we gain
Jennifer Garner what was it like having
her as a scene partner in this I mean
you guys are all you you work together
before you're all friends for years but
what was it like introducing her into
this into this element it was incredible
I still can't believe Jennifer Garner
actually did the show because we you
know this role of Evie
um when we were sort of thinking about
who who would be great to play the role
Jennifer Garner was sort of like yeah
like a Jennifer Garner type so like the
fact that we actually got Jennifer
Garner is Bonkers she is so funny and so
great and cool and I just loved working
with her
um I'd been a fan and admirer for for
years and and was so happy to finally
get to work with her was she comfortable
improvising with you guys what was that
that first day like did she have a a
feeling out of like how the flow is
gonna go before she jumps straight paid
in or what she came from from the first
take she was game from Ward one she was
hilarious and great and I think stepping
into any show where everybody knows each
other and it's you know I used to make
my living doing guest spots on TV shows
it's always uh intimidating and you feel
like the new kid in school
um but we make a real effort on party
down to for guest actors not to feel
that way
and Jennifer wasn't a guest actor she
was a series regular on the show and so
she just jumped in and uh and we made
her feel welcome but she needed zero
help she was uh she was just you know
excellent and hilarious from from day
one in episode three we've got Nick
Offerman it's almost a Parks and Rec
reunion can you take my advice I I did
thank you again I sold some of my gold
and officially Diversified my portfolio
was that like having having him you know
getting getting back together with Nick
even though you guys aren't trading
lines I mean part of the reason we don't
share the screen is Nick and I are not
on speaking terms where it's fine we're
in litigation
uh figure it out at some point it's
purely Financial we're still very close
we're just not speaking until the
litigation is settled yes exclusively
through lawyers yes no it's yeah I mean
you know Nick's one of the great uh
actors we have the last of us I was
gonna ask you if you've seen that
is that not mind-blowing yeah it's
incredible and Nick and Murray Bartlett
uh it's just beautiful and and so anyone
who watches that or anything else Nyx in
knows that he's one of our great actors
uh and so having him on the show was
lovely and it's always fun to hang out
with Nick
and I think we had shot a Parks episode
in the building that we shot that party
down episode that's fine yeah it was
just so fun it's awesome speaking of The
Last of Us one of the one of the
sentiments I saw expressed online after
that episode aired was like how are two
of the guys from Parks and Rec just
crushing the like intellectual sci-fi
emotional space right now that's
hilarious are you at work on Severance
now yeah we're in the middle of uh of
shooting uh season two right now that's
another show where it seems like you
guys are gonna be bringing in more guest
stars and co-stars what's it like
bringing in you know other Talent into
the into to play in that sandbox
oh it's great we have Alia Shaw cat and
Gwendolyn Christie and Bob Balaban and a
bunch of great people Robbie Benson just
incredible people and
um playing really interesting uh roles
and they just bring so much to it it's
it's great I feel like Severance and
also party down must be the types of
shows that lend themselves to friends of
yours that are fans of these projects
saying like I'm game like
hook me up like let's get a rope I have
so many friends that are so incredibly
talented I always feel like any time I
get to work with friends is a great and
that's part of what party down really
taught me was when you can you should
always
work with your friends because you get
to spend time with your friends which is
harder and harder as get older and
busier but also there's a comfort uh and
an unspoken sort of language there that
really helps in kind of a Endeavor like
you know acting
[Music]